on senate bill 31 senate bill 46
and at 11 15 senate bill 54.
before we get going um i'm going to read
the announcement that is required by law
thank you pam for catching up i should
have told you we were going so you could
have clicked the live stream but we
are on so good morning everyone
members using devices please remember to
mute and turn
off sound to avoid feedback and consider
turning off your
video if you're using the keyboard for
taking notes
for good signed quality we ask that
members please speak clearly with some
volume soft voices can be heard but can
be hard to understand
the microphones in the room pick up
sound very well and be careful
about side conversations
the room computer will be muted if we
recess between hearings this morning
in regards to the sign up sheet but
committee members have been provided the
sign up sheet it was closed at 8 00 a.m
this morning um if you sign up on this
bill
since 8 a.m we will not have your names
in front of us
this morning you will have an
opportunity to speak if you wish so
to do so after all the previously
registered
persons who want to speak have been
called on
you will be allowed to sign on and
register your opinion up till
11 59 tonight as to this meeting as
chair of the house election law
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020.04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills that
have been referred to the committee
from the senate and scheduled in the
house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee it is not
this chair's intent
to do so please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of this committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to compete
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been
made available to the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar in the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91 a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271 3600 or email hcsledgestate
at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes are taken
during the meeting will be by roll call
vote
and the only roll call i anticipate will
be
attendance and i ask that the clerk do
that after
uh we do the pledge of allegiance i have
a pledge in my office
a flag in my office if you do also i ask
that you join me
and then we will do the roll call i play
to the flag of the united states of
america
and to the republic for which it stands
one
thank you all right
representative wells can you take the
roll
there you go there we go all right
representative bergeron
uh i am present uh i am calling in from
home
and there is no one in the room with me
at the present time thank you
representative barry i'm president at my
home in manchester i'll probably be
joined by my cats at some point but i am
alone
representative cody i'm here i'm in
nashua i'm alone
no cats even
madam chair i am present
i am alone i'm in bedford
it can you hear us
yes okay um
representative hamlet yes hi i'm here
i'm in my home
and there's another family member in the
house
thank you representative hamer
hi i'm here in my home in manchester
all by your cell phone there
representative lane
i'm at home in concord there's one other
family member present
in the house but no one in the office
thank you
representative mcdonald i'm home and i'm
alone
representative mooney present
in merrimack at home alone
representative your head present alone
thank you representative prude home
o'brien
no representative quayley
president i'm at home in rindge in my
home office by myself thank you
representative sandler
i'm home in my home office my husband is
elsewhere in the house
thank you representative sweeney
i'm at work in my office uh there's
three other people in the building but
i'm in a room by myself
representative trojan i'm at home in my
okay representative ward uh here at home
in portsmouth two family members
wandering around the house and i'm here
okay all right thank you
it is 10.09 the first bill scheduled for
hearing at 10 o'clock
is relative to voter checklists and
modifying the absentee ballot affidavit
this is sb 31 uh
the prime sponsor of this bill is
senator gray
co-sponsors are senator ward and
representative lang i have
as being signed up to present this bill
senator gray and if
senator gray could join us and unmute i
think we will be all set good morning
senator uh good morning ma'am chairman
uh i am james gray
i represent uh district six which
is uh alton barnstead gilmanton
farmington new durham and rochester
the bill in front of you uh senate bill
does uh really two things right now
when someone either registers
and says that they uh last voted
uh especially out of state but uh even
in state
uh that information is put into election
net and
this shifts the responsibility of
notifying
the out-of-state people
from the town clerk and the supervisors
of the checklist
to the secretary of state they can
gather these things up
with the contacts that they have through
the secretary of state's network
and provide that information and also
get that information from
the other states that we're doing this
with
that's the surrounding states and it
should mean
a much more efficient and
easier process on the towns to complete
that and to keep their
their checklist updated with the
information that's provided
[Music]
the other portion of this has to do with
the
absentee affidavit
both of these items were talked about in
the interviews that were done with the
secretary of state after the last
election
and they noted that there was people if
they had a problem with the affidavit
sometimes
they didn't sign either one and when
they were
asked about it they were confused about
which one to sign
there's really no reason in state law
that we need to have
two separate affidavits this combines
the reason at the top of the form
lets you sign one place
and that combined with some other
legislation that you'll get
about opening the outer envelope sooner
should ensure that even if someone does
make a mistake
uh that there will be ample time for
them to correct it
uh but like i say with this piece of
legislation
um the first section that i talked about
should
make it more accurate the information
going back and forth between
us vermont maine etc
and also in here reducing the confusion
of the voter of which affidavit they
should be signing so
i'd be happy to take any questions you
have
thank you senator gray does anybody on
the committee
um i see one hand
hold on representative bergeron
yeah thank you madam chairman um and
welcome senator gray
mike my question deals with the first
section
654 654-13 action by supervisors
lines eight through ten um it states
that if a person
enters uh the place last register
registered to vote on the voter
registration form it shall be entered
into the statewide
voter registration database there's
already a statute that
i guess maybe it doesn't demand that
they do it but there's already a statute
that says
the the form and the database shall
include
the current information on the voter
registration forms
pertaining to last place registered to
vote
why is there a need to have this in two
different statutes
there probably isn't this wording
was provided to me by the secretary of
state's office
and i don't believe that it conflicts in
any way
and having it in both parts of the
statute
having it here i think promotes
readability of the statute
uh without having to go to another
statute to read
what it says there okay if your
committee decides that you want to do
something different
certainly we'll review it when it gets
okay thank you senator no further
questions does anybody else on the
committee have
all right i'm not seeing any thank you
senator gray for coming and joining us
this morning
is there anyone else in attendance that
would like to speak
on this bill
we have 12 attendees i'm looking for
somebody to see if they want to speak
and raise their hand
up uh mr meyer joins us this morning
mr meyer if you unmute i think you
will be able to join us
uh good morning uh chairwoman uh a
member
of the comm my name is lucas meyer i
live in manchester new hampshire
uh signed in as a neutral to this bill
um and
uh my focus of attention is on actually
section
3 of the bill which
instructs the secretary of state
establish
essentially their own version of a a
crosscheck
program or an interstate program
to monitor movements in and out of the
state change of addresses
which i think a good idea
but what i would direct the committee's
attention to
is the electronic registration
information center
also known as eric um which was founded
uh in 2012 as part of the pew
charitable trust but has now been taken
over by the member states
um of which there are many um a majority
of states are now
members of eric um and these are uh
republican controlled state
democratic controlled states um and eric
was created to fix
a major challenge facing election
officials um and that's how to ensure
easy access to voter registration while
maintaining accurate voter lists
in this difficult for election officials
to do particularly now in days as
you know americans move around so much
um inexpensive research confirms that
there's mobility can make it hard for
voters to keep up to date
for example in the past 10 years i've
lived in newmarket i've lived in ward 2
manchester ward 3 manchester so
you know me alone i i i appear
on many different motor lists so um
since voter lists and records can be out
of date
election officials can send information
to voters who do not exist
voters who cannot receive information
from where they've moved
or how to vote when voters don't have
that correct information they end up
having problems at the polls
leading to longer lines frustration
all things that can be avoided uh so
eric is a sophisticated data center
governed again
by the state to choose to participate um
which helps keep these voters up to date
while also increasing access to voter
registration for eligible citizens
again 31 states plus the district of
columbia are members
and notably both florida and
massachusetts
are member states of eric and why i draw
attention
to those two states in particular is
that
during our participation in cross
check the some run out of kansas which
is now
um defunct and uh no longer operating
a majority of those duplicates that were
flagged for the secretary of state
came from florida and massachusetts
what's
what makes a lot of sense if you lived
in new hampshire for any period of time
so both of those states are members of
this existing program
as well as a majority of northeastern
states
and so what does eric do and what are
the benefits for new hampshire
one it's going to identify millions of
voters who have moved within
state and out of state you know they've
identified
2.5 million voters who moved out of
state and therefore no longer eligible
to vote in that state
over 240 000 voter records for
individuals who have passed away
since they last voted over 320
000 duplicate registration records um
in all total since 2018 eric is
responsible for correcting
over 10 million voter records were no
longer
accurate so this really does a good
job of making sure
we are catching double registrations
we're tracking who's moving in state
out of state and there's all of this
will be done for new hampshire
as a member of eric um for a very
nominal cost
of you know the the first year um of
eric membership which includes an entry
fee
due would be around 50 to 60 thousand
dollars
mr myers this is a representative
griffin
um are you testifying about the state
joining
eric or are you testifying about the
bill because i don't see a fiscal note
on this bill
and i didn't take this bill to mean we
were joining eric and
senator gray is still online perhaps you
can respond after you finish
thank you my the reason i bring up
eric is i believe i i would encourage
the committee to consider an amendment
for section
three senses instructing the secretary
state to build a program
that already exists in the form of eric
so it seems to me to be a colossal waste
of taxpayer dollars
for the secret secretary of state to
build an independent system
from what already exists that we could
become a member of and join a majority
of states
that would accomplish the goals fourth
in
that amendment in section three of the
bill
are there any further questions from
represent for
mr meyer from committee members yes
ma'am can i have a question
representative barry uh mr meyers did
you say that massachusetts was a member
of eric
uh they are in the process of becoming
okay so they're not currently a member
but they have passed legislation to join
and
and also the technically hampshire does
not need legislation to enter into eric
secretary of state could could do that
on his own
um you know be good forever to be on
senator greg lord as a member
mr meyer you just told us massachusetts
was a member and apparently they're not
so perhaps you can follow up in writing
as to who exactly is a member of eric
thank you senator gray did you want to
respond
um certainly over the past uh six seven
years
we have had the discussion about
cross-check and eric
several times it was brought up in the
last sessions
you know eric is out there eric requires
you to do several things beyond
this cross-checking of information it
prescribes how you were going to solicit
new voters uh parts of the things that
are in eric are also considered
in the u.s house bill h.r
one um and we might be having a
different conversation had
had that bill been passed by both the
house and the senate and signed by the
president
but it is not this is not a new system
the system out there uh often referred
to
as the election net is existing it
already has the capability to produce
the files
that would be transmitted to the other
states
so this is a no-cost option that's why
you don't have a fiscal note
and if the good representative wants to
introduce
a bill that mandates that the state go
into eric
i'm sure that next november when we open
up the
ability for him to file that legislation
he may do so
further questions or comments from
um let me go to is there anybody else
attending this meeting
from the public who would like to
us
i believe i have pam if you're on it i
believe i
promoted miss spencer she hasn't
she's with us i'm so sorry i
i've didn't unmute myself i apologize
for that okay
good morning good morning um hello
members of the committee and thank you
madam chair for
uh taking my testimony this morning um
i did want to speak to to section three
of the bill
as well uh because i think it is
so essential this component that we have
accurate voting rolls
it is the foundation of ensuring safe
and secure elections
it's what inspires confidence that those
who are voting are in fact current
eligible voters reduces the risk of
identity fraud
saves time for the state and local
workers who administer
our elections and and it reduces costs
so i think we all agree
here that um and i know that you as
members of the election
um law committee know this better than
than most
folks uh the national conference of
state legislators has said that the goal
of maintaining an accurate voter list is
to ensure
that eligible voters are able to cast a
ballot
to keep track of who has voted to
prevent anyone from voting twice
and by reducing inaccuracies speed up
the voter check-in process at polling
places
voter registration lists they also say
are the foundation of everything else in
election administration
so just underscoring that really
important point
and section three of this bill
recognizes the importance
of accurate voting lists the question is
how do we get there
and um as mr meyer testified there are
tools out there
and eric is is one such
tool um that i think it is
it would be helpful for this committee
to take a look at
in the context of of this bill
i've over the course of the last
election cycle i sat
in on many many supervisors of the
checklists
um meetings and election net while being
a helpful tool
is by far um
from being the tool that is needed by
these election workers
um in fact one day i went to supervisors
of the checklist
meeting that had to be postponed because
uh election net was down and when
everybody
signs in all at once when when these
meetings are held on the same day
leading
up to elections uh the system gets
overloaded
um the beauty of a system like eric
is that it allows states to be uploading
i mean towns i'm sorry
to be um getting the data on a regular
rolling basis
uh so that they can update um as they go
along
also many times i was in on discussions
where supervisors were saying they were
not able to access
particular information about voters
and were trying to have to resort to
arcane methods of mix and match and
guessing about whether they were talking
about the same voter in fact i've
witnessed
where they were unable to they actually
because of the difficulty in matching
this information
um made some mistakes about recommending
who should be removed
from the polls one thing i would like to
say is that a tool like eric
is really it is just that
it's a tool it does not require
the state to do anything in other words
it provides data that the state
can use i do agree with senator gray
that in the instance of eric it does
have some um the members do agree to
take certain steps in reaching out to
unregistered voters which i think is
actually
a net benefit of a program like eric
but in terms of the data itself that is
stand-alone reporting that comes back to
the states
that then can be used as a tool so i've
seen the frustration that supervisors of
the checklist have
this is a problem that we need to
address there is
a tool out there and available and to be
suggesting that as the secretary of
state i know
has done in several meetings uh and
hearings that i've been a part of that
we should build our own tool
uh really um is going to present a cost
to the state that that is pretty hefty
um if not insurmountable
and and requires a degree of
investment of time and resources that um
seems unwise when we have such a good
tool
as eric available so i too would
recommend and hope
that you would be looking at
adopting or having
an amendment brought before this
committee so that
you could really take a good look i
think we saw
that elections you know we we all
it's a bipartisan issue we all agree
that we need to ensure the safe
and secure elections and the confidence
that people have in our elections so
thank you
thank you does anybody have any
questions for ms spencer
representative mirrorhead did you have a
question if you can unmute
yep i'm not seeing his hand anymore okay
all right thank you miss spencer is
there anybody else in attendance thank
you
on this bill hb excuse me sb
all right i'm not seeing anybody so
thank you very much everybody i'm going
to close the public hearing
on sb 31 it is 10
30 so i am going to open the public
hearing
on sd 46 sb 46 is relative to the use of
electronic poll books by cities and
towns
um with us today we have
a number of speakers signed up and
um i guess i'd like to uh
know who is here to introduce it
uh senator the senator's hand is up
and senator you are with us if you could
introduce
committee
is she with us pam yes
yes senator welcome good morning how are
you good morning
thank you chairwoman i'm well how are
you good
all right that's sb 46
thanks very much so um good morning
everyone
for the record i'm senator rebecca
perkins quoca i represent senate
district 21 which is
portsmouth and surrounding towns on the
seacoast i'm prime sponsor of sb46
an act relative to the use of electronic
poll books by cities and towns
a pilot program on the use of electronic
pool books began around 2015.
the towns that have been involved have
had a very good experience
and are anxious to make the program
permanent specifically i've spoken to
the town clerk of milford who has
participated in the pilot program she's
very supportive of this spell
i'm not aware of any issues that have
arisen with the electronic pullback
system
and the pilot the language involved in
sb-46 would create an entirely opt-in
system for our municipalities and no
municipality would be forced to adopt
electronic poll books if they did not
wish to
an electronic poll book is a small
administrative change that will be used
on election day
instead of having paper checklists towns
that choose to use poll books will have
the information
electronically on a computer or ipad
such devices can or cannot be hooked up
to wi-fi
although i'll address that further below
poll books will speed up lines at
polling places
which will decr decrease waiting times
for voters and it makes elections
officials jobs easier
not only with less people flowing
through the point not only with people
flowing through the polling place
quicker
but poll books tabulate all of the
information that election officials have
to collect at the end of the election
saving municipalities time and money
the process on election day would remain
largely the same
the voters would be asked to provide the
same documentation they are now
if they do not have documentation they
will be able to sign an affidavit
the hope is that electronic pullbooks
simply provide a quicker check-in and
shutdown for the clerks
they also can enable additional ways to
back up the checkup information
as some towns have used the electronic
system alongside a paper system in order
to create duplicates
after extensive conversation with the
secretary of state's office in the
senate
process under the current language of
the bill the poll books will be
will need to be approved by the
secretary of state
as the and they are not comfortable at
this time approving the systems for
voter
registration which is another capability
of the poll books
that would require connecting the
machines to wi-fi or the internet
which is a process the sos needs more
time to vet
so at this time the ask is simply to
allow the use of electronic pull books
once approved by the secretary of state
for voter checking
that said the hope is that we have
electronic pullbacks available as an
option for voter check-in for the
municipal elections for the fall
so that the clerks wish they are able to
use the system in a live election prior
to the federal and state elections next
year
thank you very much madam chairwoman for
the opportunity present and i'm happy to
answer
any questions although there are some
here who may be better equipped to
answer those questions
thank you senator uh is there are there
any members of the question
of representative terozian thank you
madam chair
and thank you thank you senator for
taking my question i think i heard you
say that
um if this is adopted the idea is to
at some point have the ability in
essence have
um uh polling places be connected to the
uh internet did i hear that correctly
and could you elaborate on the reason
for that
sure and and just to restate that's not
the proposal
this year though this legislation would
enable the secretary of state to approve
poll books
in conversation with them and i don't
know if deputy scanlan is available
today but
um you know that that process would take
some time so
um that's not what we're proposing to be
available this year but
yes eventually you know um like any
computer
or ipad uh these the software could be
hooked up to the internet and it could
be used for voter registration so in
other words the system would be
updated live for voters that choose to
take advantage of same-day registration
on election day
thank you thank you representative lane
uh thank you madam chair um senator
uh why is it the secretary of state is
approving the poll books rather than the
ballot commission because i think it's
the ballot commission that approves the
voting system if i'm not the voting
machines if i'm not mistaken
um that is a very good question
representative i unfortunately don't
think i'm the
right person to answer that but i do
hope um we can defer that question
potentially to one of the other speakers
and i'll make sure that it's answered
for you
thank you representative prudhomme
o'brien
thank you and thank you rep senator
perkins coca
can you can everyone hear me okay yeah
we can hear you fine
excellent so my question is about
section
uh four at the end and it talks about
um the secretary of state preparing
a regularly updated set of instructions
and best use practices for the use of
electronic poll books
is that where the uh the
connected to the internet would be
addressed
um it could be yep and i think there are
some
other references in here i'm just i'm
just looking
for example in section two um
in the third line it references approval
by the secretary of state so
yes both of those references and
actually the first sentence of section
three i'll i'll refer to how
um the secretary of state would be able
to approve
these devices for successive uses over
time
sorry i did not mean to raise my hand
[Laughter]
um
uh anybody else on the committee who has
a
question for the senator madam chairman
representative mcdonald thank you madam
chairman
you need to get together with
representative murrah he raises his hand
when he doesn't want to talk and you
can't
yeah so you too right now but then it
went down without me
lowering it i don't know what happened
[Laughter]
again thank you madam chairman and good
morning senator good morning
my hometown of londonderry actually has
been using the um
this this system on the last couple of
elections
would they have had to get permission
from the secretary of state to do that
uh thank you representative that's a
good question under
the pilot program i believe that
um each town that wanted to use a new
vendor
needed to have that vendor approved and
i i believe that would have been a
process through the secretary of state
but
i i would actually like to make sure
that that's true and ask that one of the
later speakers confirm that for you but
again i'll make sure that you get the
answer to that question
thank you and follow up madam chairman
go ahead representative
um senator uh so is the purpose of your
bill to basically achieve a uniformity
and a
careful regulation of this system should
it go statewide or be
more widely used uh
yes i think that's one of the purposes i
mean this is a tool that
hopefully will save our municipalities
time and money you know i know
from my years on city council in
portsmouth that election days are long
days they're 15 or 16 hour days for our
clerks and so
um yes i think uniformity is a good
thing i also think
options are a good thing and so not
every city or town may be ready to adopt
this yet and
until they are you know we may not get
to that uniformity but
the hope is that um now that we've had a
successful pilot program that we're just
simply giving our towns and cities more
tools to do their job thank you
thank you further questions from
panelists
uh thank you senator not
signed up to speak per se but with their
hand raised and i think would be helpful
for the committee to hear from now would
be deputy
scanlon deputy scanlon you have joined
us
welcome this morning on sb 46.
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlan deputy
secretary of state
uh here to support this bill and i have
enjoyed working with senator
cuoca on moving the issue of
e-pull books forward just a little bit
of history a few years ago
the legislature did approve a trial
program
for electronic poll books which involved
a
first of all a town or towns or cities
interested
in testing them to
make that decision and then work with
an evaluation vendor which is designed
to
look at the electronic poll books in use
take a look at their security
look for vulnerabilities and and the
overall
usability in the polling place there
have been
i believe four towns
in new hampshire uh there have been four
there have been four cities and towns in
new hampshire that have
attempted to use them uh but
londonderry and milford have been using
them now for a couple of years
in a in a kind of a quasi-test format
the report from the evaluation vendor
at this point is incomplete
on both of those poll books
they have found some vulnerabilities i
know that you know that the vendors are
working on addressing those but i think
what we have learned
and this will all come out in a report
that's due in november
to the legislature is that uh
simply looking at an electronic poll
book in its entirety
and trying to approve it is
a a lot too a lot to deal with um
the the towns that have been how are you
um the towns that have been using them
have been using them
uh in parallel with the current uh
check-in system
but they have realized some real
benefits in terms of
the efficiency of the line at the
polling place
and then gathering and reporting all of
the data that they need at the end of
the night after the
polls close so this bill
would allow that process to move forward
in a more formal
way and save the issues related to
voter registration on the electoral book
for down the road because those
those issues a lot more complicated when
we're dealing with
you know how do we integrate that
information directly with
voter database election net um
is it going to be hardwired connection
is it going to be
wi-fi um and if it is i mean those are
issues where
there are real security concerns and
there have been failures
in those systems in other states um
we are going to be meeting with uh the
clerks and the moderators
from the towns of milford and
londonderry next monday
uh to start the process of just
reviewing where they're at
how we can move this this
tool forward uh you know anticipating
the passage of this legislation
so that we can make the system more
broadly available to other
cities and towns in the state and then
in an incremental way
components of the system uh you know
moving in the direction of using it for
voter registration
as well and we believe that process is
prudent
uh it makes sense for the for the state
of new hampshire
and it allows the towns to be able to
use
the benefits of these systems by
reducing their lines at the polling
place and being being able to report
results
much faster at the end of the night when
i say results results in terms of
voter check-in information um which
does take them some time to do after the
polls close
so with that um oh representative lane
did ask a question about why doesn't the
beltlock commission
approve these devices the statute
gives the responsibility to the ballot
lock commission of approving
electronic ballot counting devices but
a poll book is not an electronic
counting device
it's something different i mean
certainly if the legislature wants to
include them
in the uh approval process um
you know i don't think that we would
oppose that belt law commission might
because it's more more work for them but
um
that's the reason why uh you know the
language and the bill did not include
the belt law commission uh from the
start so with that madam chair i would
be happy to answer any other questions
thank you i always defer to deputy
scanlon as the master
of this zoom meeting right having run
the meetings last summer with hundreds
of people attending
uh representative terozzian did you
thank you madam chair
and thank you deputy scanlan for taking
my question so i just
want a couple of points of clarification
if i may so
i heard i believe i heard you say the
towns of londonderry and milton
have been using this kind of as a test
pilot program are there any other
municipalities using it
i believe that rochester at one point
tried them out and i believe that
manchester
uh at one point may have tried them out
there are two different
uh vendors that provide the machines the
one that is used
in milford is known as electec
and the one that is used in londonderry
is known as
no inc and their product is called the
follow-up question madam chair
representative go ahead
thank you so um would
would you like to see more testing then
uh prior to this becoming a
potentially permanent um edition
and would um is this legislation needed
to
to have other towns do testing of this
and and get more data
um i think we have reached the point now
where we can move the trial
forward into a program in terms of using
the devices
for check-in i think that that they have
the the trials that these two towns have
done
in that regard show that they do work
and that they're a useful tool
and they they can make the process in
the towns more efficient
um i think we need to continue the work
where uh where we might consider
uh using the devices for voter
registration at the polling place
uh in the future i think that there's
still a lot that has to be
vetted uh in that regard and so
um the the bill is necessary because the
trial program ends
uh at the end of this year and this is
the next logical step to move
uh the process forward and uh as i
mentioned at the beginning
we are in agreement with that thank you
very much
representative o'brien thank you deputy
scanlan taking my question
my question is a bit of a two-parter
i would like to know why the the city
ward in manchester
and the city of rochester had previously
participated
in the trial but then did not
continue with that that's is that
correct
do you know why and then my other
question is about vulnerabilities you
said some vulnerabilities were found
but what were those specifically talk
about that a bit thank you
thank you representative um the the
first question
i don't know the reason why uh
manchester and rochester
only uh use the devices once
um uh i don't know if senator gray is
able to comment on rochester
but but i don't know the answer to that
i don't specifically know what they are
i know that the the evaluation vendor
uh was not able to just give the devices
a clean bill of health
um they are required to give us a report
uh which we have not yet received
um and when they do that will be
that information will be made public and
will be part of the report
uh that we issue in november
however uh in terms of the voter
check-in
uh and the way that process has worked
with the safeguards that are currently
in place
i i think that's a pretty safe system to
use and
the the concern there obviously is that
if the devices crashed
or were unable to
continue in use after the polls had
opened
to be able to fall back onto a
you know the the paper system that we
have in place so that we can continue
the election without
lines forming and kind of losing track
of where we are and i think that
the trials that have been undertaken in
both milford
and londonderry have shown uh that we
can do that
and so our comfort level has gone way up
senator gray did you want to comment uh
thank you
madam chairman uh rochester has six
wards
we did the test in one of the wards
it was all equipment that was lent to us
by one of the vendors and as far as i
know
because of the other tests that are
ongoing right now that
opportunity has not been provided to us
for the other awards or for an ongoing
basis even in ward 4.
deputy scanlon and
perhaps senator gray you could answer
this
there was some talk about paper backups
in case there's a problem then the
election can continue
have there been any problems such as
that in new hampshire i know we'll only
have the two communities
four that have used it have there been
any
problems where they then had to use the
paper backups in new hampshire
how did that go um madam chair and
representative o'brien
i am not aware of the trial towns having
any issues
with the poll books uh that they have
used
they both of the towns are using a paper
backup system
so that they're keeping track of the
voters that are going through
uh independently of the
at the check-in by the elect electronic
poll book
so if at any point uh during the
election there had been a failure
uh they would be up to date within 10 or
15 minutes
and and could put in
place a paper checklist to continue
the process moving forward with a very
representative mcdonald
representative mcdonald you need to
unmute
sorry thank you um um
just a comment uh and i would refer to
our town clerk sherry farrell but by all
indications that i'm aware of
the system has worked very well for
londonderry so far
in every election when we've used it so
it has it has proven beneficial from
what i can see
deputy scanlon this is barbara griffin i
have a question
um i am aware that there are other
jurisdiction
voting precincts not in new hampshire
that have used electronic poll books
where the electronic poll books have
malfunctioned
resulting in court proceedings to extend
the time the polls are open for the
amount
of time the poll books are were down
and i note that you say that we're doing
a paper
checklist parallel and there's a lag
time but if i go to
the first page of the bill line 26
section 1 it provides that
or a paper checklist shall be marked in
parallel
so is a parallel checklist
required or not
and if it's not if the electronic pull
books go
down how do you then switch to
a paper checklist that has not been
getting completed
in parallel thank you uh thank you madam
chair
and i believe the language in the bill
uh gives the flexibility
uh to require a
you know a paper checklist in parallel
with the electronic poll book which is
uh pretty much the
practice right now that is occurring in
londonderry
and milford there may be at some point
um you know enough
you know enough practice with these
devices enough experience
and enough confidence that you know we
can move away from that
process in the future but that would
only happen
if if we know that we can conduct an
election
uh uh you know without the potential for
the failure because where it has
happened
uh it it has been catastrophic
and obviously that's something that we
don't want to have
happen in new hampshire and uh you know
and we would
make sure that we have proper procedures
in place
to deal with that if it were to occur so
um hopefully that that answers your
question but
uh i don't believe that that we would
approve
a system where we would simply rely on
the
electronic poll book until we have a lot
more information
uh you know relative to their ability to
to not malfunction well deputy if you
could take another look at the bill
because i think this bill proposes
exactly that that the paper checklist
is an alternative that's available and
okay representative
o'brien has her hand up thank you
deputy scanlon i'm not sure if this is a
question exactly but but i'll try to
phrase it as one
if the possibility for catastrophic
how is this an improvement over over
paper poll books i i understand
wanting to make the whole process go
faster but i think
yeah how is it an improvement i'm just
uh thank you representative o'brien so
the way the system uh has been working
now is
that that the polling places have been
following the statutory process
in the law which involves a paper
checklist which has to be marked off
as a voter goes through the towns
that are using the devices have decided
to use them in addition to the statutory
process that is currently
taking place and even by doing so
the benefit that they are realizing is
that
the voters showing up at the polling
place does not have to get in a line
first of all by
the alphabet of the first letter in
their last name
they can go into any line that is the
shortest and
check in and then
uh and then there's a process there's a
slip that comes off that can be taken to
the
supervisors that are marking the
checklist the name is marked off
checklist uh with a bit of a lag time
but
but the paper checklist is being
maintained at that point
so that's a time savings right there um
and helps keep the lines in the polling
place moving
the real benefit however is at the end
of the night when the polls close
and the poll workers the supervisors of
the checklist are charged with
collecting the information off the paper
checklist
in terms of how many voters checked in
in the case of a primary
might be which which primary ballot they
took
and things like that as that information
is
entered into the electronic poll book as
the voters check in
that information is immediately
available at the end of the night when
the polls close simply by
pressing a couple keys on the you know
on the laptop
uh that keeps that information and
that's a tremendous time savings
for the towns in that regard and
and so those two those two items alone
uh have been the real benefit that the
towns have seen
uh regarding these devices and i'm not
sure if if the clerks or the moderators
from milford or londonderry are
going to testify but you know they could
probably give you a better
you know a better explanation of
of that savings um uh
you know with their testimony thank you
senator gray
uh thank you madam chairman i just
wanted to comment on a couple of those
um there's also savings after election
day
is that the town clerks go back into
election net
and mark you down as voted not voted
if it's a primary they also take and
mark up
what ballot that you've took um whether
you returned to your undeclared status
and that is another savings in addition
to the savings at uh
election day um the uh
there was another point i was going to
comment on uh but it escapes my mind
right now if i remember i'll i'll be
back with you if you have
any addition oh the
paper checklist okay that
the receipt that you get okay if the
voters are
allowed to go to any of the machines
okay then
the paper checklist isn't there for you
to mark it up
so there are schemes out there that says
that you would take that piece of
paper use that to get your ballot
and then that piece of paper would be
given to a clerk and the clerk would
mark up the checklist
from that slip of paper that was printed
out for when you voted
uh there's also talk about putting a qr
code on it
and having another computer there that
would scan that
and then automatically make up the
checklist
but that would mean that you would have
to go back and
actually print the checklist in that 10
minute time frame that is talked about
uh in communities that have uh you know
more than 20 000 voters in the community
that becomes very difficult to do
so just those two comments i appreciate
you
uh giving me the opportunity all right
we'll let you jump back in at any time
all right
uh is there anybody else on the
committee representative growing
thank you madam chair uh
deputy secretary scanlan if
you've mentioned that there are
vulnerabilities that there have been
some significant security failures in
other states
that have been catastrophic wouldn't it
be better at this point
to extend the trial period rather than
make this
a a permanent feature as it appears
thank you representative growing for
that question um
i believe that we are ready to to move
the ball forward
on this understanding that
that there are there's a lot of
functionality to these devices
it's clear to me that that if we have to
approve the device
in in in one motion that it's going to
be a long time
coming um i think i think
the the great thing about this
legislation is that it allows
us the process to approve the
functionality
in an incremental way where can
can realize the benefits of using them
where we are comfortable
that the technology is is going to be
safe and
it's not going to impact
our election process if they go down
i think all of you know if you've been
following you know the
secretary of state's use of technology
you know in other areas in the state
is that we are very very cautious about
uh you know about going with newer
technology for these reasons is
that you know other states that have
that have tried things
um and and had failures
experienced real problems at the polling
place and and
we're we're pretty adverse to that so
we're not going to approve something
technologically unless we are really
sure
uh that has it has been properly vetted
that you know the experts
you know have taken a look at it and and
have that confidence that
the system is going to work and not and
not
cause a failed election so um we are
comfortable
uh using the device where we know that
that it's going to function properly
um but we're also willing to look at the
other functionality uh again in an
incremental way so that
uh you know we're comfortable uh
seeing those benefits moving forward
once once we're confident that
they're fail safe
i'm not seeing any so uh thank you
deputy scanlon for joining us i'm going
to move on
to people who have signed up ahead of
time to speak
if they would raise their hand um i will
recognize them
um is there a joan doggie here
a pete mr basilier um
thank you very much you are with us if
you want to unmute you can speak to this
bill welcome
uh thank you very much uh madam
chairwoman and uh
good morning everyone on the committee
and other others um
yes i am the town moderator in milford
i've been the town and school
district moderator now for uh 13 years
and have participated with our town
clerk
joan dodgey in implementing the tests
that have been referred to
earlier today in milford we use the
electech brand of e poll book
and that process involves having the
voter checklist after the last
supervisors of the checklist meeting
prior to an election that list is
downloaded onto the e-poll book
and then the e-poll books are brought to
the polling place
in electex implementation
in the way we use it in milford the
e-poll books are all hardwired one to
another
so there is no internet access
um on the e-poll books
and in fact the poll books and our
implementation are our computers
and they don't have wireless features on
those computers
when when a voter approaches the the
ballot clerk
and successfully checks in the voter is
handed a
a slip of paper much like a receipt that
you might
receive at a retail outlet and that
slip of paper has the information the
public information about the voter
their name their address their party
affiliation
and before the voter leaves that station
we ask the voter to
double check to make sure that the
information on the slip of paper
which is the record that we have for
them in the checklist
is correct um so once that's
once the voter has reviewed the slip of
paper that we give them
they go to a common location where they
exchange the slip of paper
for a ballot if it's a primary
it's the obviously it'll be the party
ballot and if it's a local election it
would be the town and school district
ballot that slip of paper is retained by
the clerks who are handing out the
ballots
and then periodically throughout the day
uh those slips of paper
are gathered up put into alphabetical
order
and we have a set of clerks who are
marking on a paper checklist the voters
who have checked in
during the course of the day so as uh
deputy scanlan pointed out
and as noted in the proposed legislation
we are we are making a copy of
the names of people who have uh checked
in successfully
in near real time um depending upon the
number of people in the in the
polling place at the moment it's it's in
that 10 or 15 minute
window that is referred to in in the
legislative proposed legislation
now when we think about catastrophic
failure remembering that
the implementation we have in milford is
not connected to the internet
that they're hardwired the machines are
all hardwired to each other and in
in the case of the match election just
passed we use
six books last fall in november we used
12.
when they're when they're all linked
together if it's a catastrophic failure
it's i it's it's uh would be depending
upon your definition of
catastrophe it could be one machine that
goes down
in which case all the others are still
up and running and still can process
voters
if several or all of the machines go
down that's when
we we would revert to the paper
checklist
so anticipating the possibility
of a failure as moderator when i set up
the check
the polling places the night before i
make provision
for being able to change over to paper
checklist and remove the paper ballots
put up the signposts that indicate the
letters of the alphabet and so forth
and the time it would take us to relay
out
the polling place by removing those
electronic
e-poll books and implementing the paper
checklist
is about the time time that it would
take us to catch up
so that we have recorded on the paper
checklist all the voters who have
checked in prior to the failure of the e
poll book
so we do have a paper backup
that is going to provide us the
provides me as a moderator and it
provides the voters with an assurance
that if there is a failure in the e-poll
books
that we have the ability with negligible
if any delay in the process
aside from changing over from electronic
to paper
that we can make that happen and we have
a paper backup
that will be used generally speaking if
there's a question about the poll books
after the fact
or in the case of a catastrophic failure
so again i just wanted to stress that in
our implementation
the electec books are all wired each to
what
each other um in milford we've been
using it for well over two years now
starting with a local election we've
used it in the primary
use in the general election and the
national election last fall
with no issues whatsoever
and as i point out if there was an issue
the change over time is negligible
and one last point um is that
if i if you take the pole books away the
they love them you know it's it's like
well first come first serve
uh first person in the in the polling
place it gets checked in and the next
one behind them they don't have to wait
in line with all the other m's or
c's or whatever so thank you for
listening to my uh
comments and i'm welcomed i'm happy to
take any questions
madam chairwoman that you may allow
thank you does anybody on the committee
have any questions for
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us today and giving us your
experience
um you mentioned and i have on the list
i'm going to ask again
um i'm going to ask if cordell jones
don't oh
can you hear that i can't you're you're
you're uh
uh code so i didn't realize it was all
i'm sorry
welcome i clicked the wrong line when i
signed in
okay so uh one thing uh representative
griff
and thank you everybody for um hearing
my testimony again
um uh for representative griffin when
you were asking about the
the um the or paper checklist
that's in reference to we are required
enough high-speed color printers on hand
or the paper checklist we opted for the
paper checklist because i did some
research
into what the cost of having high-speed
printers that could print out
our 800-page 900-page
checklist in less than 50 minutes and it
would have cost us 24 000
so we opted to get use our volunteers
and fill out a paper checklist in the
back of the room
um the other thing that you asked about
was catastrophic failure
and um when i looked into the
catastrophic
failure that happened with poll books
in the united states mariposa county is
the one that comes to mind
and their catastrophic failure was they
never set the poll books up correctly
to start in the morning so when people
arrived at six a.m
they had no backup and they in their id
department had not
put them together correctly so
i i sort of that was in uh preparation
for the election
i felt because i really looked into what
could be catastrophic failures
um on another note it was and i'm not
sure if manchester
did do a pilot with these but it was
bedford that did the um
the test um uh
so i'm i'm i'm not aware of manchester
actually um ever doing one um it was
bedford
and uh the
and again um oh in the vulnerability
abilities i've been working a lot with
our elect tech book vendor
and um the volume
found some issues with the system but
there's no vulnerabilities on at least
the ones that we're using
with um it was cyberscout that
did the came to our site and they did a
security check while we were using the
whole books
um the the issues that are that they
found are all in the background in
auditing um and i guess i'd question
whether that's
necessary because the auditing that
they're looking at like today with a
paper checklist
one of the benefits that came up uh
during covet
was that i had a voter who came in and
voted with covid
i was able to go into the electronic
poll book
and see exactly what time they checked
in and who the
who the ballot clerks that were working
at that time which is a great feature
uh the the cyber scout who was looking
into the background of the system wants
it even more detailed than that but i
mean i could
our person that came and checked in with
kobit came in at 10 29
you know and um and we can tell exactly
what poll book they checked in on
um i i you know i i know everybody's
heard all this before
debbie scanlan did a great job of of of
um talking about everything
and uh i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you does anybody from the
committee have any questions for miss
dorgie
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us
thank you also signed up to speak with
cordell johnstone
mr johnstone you are with us if you
unmute you will
uh good morning i think it's yes good
morning madam chair
um cordell johnson representing the new
hampshire municipal association
um and i just uh want to agree with
uh uh to the extent that i understand
the technology i certainly agree with
everything that others have said
um and uh the
municipal association is very much in
support of
this legislation uh i'm
i have talked to uh uh pete besseler
from
milford quite a bit about it and he
raves all the time
and um i know that there are other towns
that are
very interested in pursuing this maybe
not immediately but
in the near future um
the i i i think there are probably a lot
of towns smaller towns that would not
pursue this because there is a cost to
it the the
the cost of the poll books is borne by
the town so it's a
matter of uh figuring out whether it's
worth
the expense and the effort but for the
larger towns in the cities
um it really it really is a
time saving and uh and
many of our members would be interested
in pursuing it
uh that's all i'll all i have to say
unless anyone has any questions
thank you thank you does anybody have
i'm not seeing any so thank you for
joining us that concludes the persons
who have signed up ahead of time to
speak on this
uh michael o'brien joins us and he has
asked to speak to this bill good morning
mr o'brien
thank you representative members of the
committee my name is michael o'brien
um i just want to clear up a couple of
things um i'm sorry with pretty
strategies on behalf of my client
america votes
um i used to work directly for american
votes for for years and worked on
electronic pull books
um through the trial um and so
have uh some history with these couple
things uh one manchester never ran a
trial
just so folks know that um that never
happened
um and so i know there was some question
about that
um i think this might have been covered
but i do want to say to your question
representative griffin the full sentence
in the
um in the proposed legislation
says that you can either do a printer a
high-speed printer
or a backup paper checklist so the
high-speed paper printer um
would cost the towns a lot of money and
that's why they decide not to do a lot
of times they want to do that but
either way you're gonna have something
that creates an effective backup right
away
um and then as far as some of the things
that we've heard about
problems with the e-pullbooks most of
these problems were
um driven by the user so we look back in
georgia
for instance there was one where they
tried to open up the polling place and
there was
um you know there was no data on the
poll book but that was because the
person who runs their election i don't
know what the name of that person would
be in georgia here we call him the
moderator obviously
didn't upload the list to the pull book
so when he turned it on there was
nothing there
that's user error it's not public error
and because in
this legislation we are requiring paper
checklists we can be rest assured that
if that were to happen
um that we would have a paper list there
ready to be used
additionally so folks know if there was
like a power outage or something that
happened in the town not only would we
have the paper
checklist but much like every electronic
device that we own
um these things run on batteries right
they don't if the power goes off they're
not going to turn off and
lose all connection to the world um they
will
still be operational in use and again
because we're not using internet with
them
we don't worry about losing the wi-fi et
cetera et cetera
but all of that also gets solved with
the backup paper checklist which this
legislation
mandates so i'm happy to answer any
questions um but just wanted to clear up
some things that i heard
during uh the question and answers from
does anybody have any questions for mr
o'brien
i'm not seeing any hands mr o'brien this
is representative griffin
back to the catastrophic failure there
seems to be a lot of reliance based on
the fact that you can print
the list if the town has opted for a
high-speed printer
uh when there is a catastrophic failure
um is there any guarantee that a
catastrophic failure
isn't going to be a shutdown of the pull
books
and at that point then printing a list
is impossible
or am i missing something i think
printing the list would be hard like if
you lost power
um you could still print it at city hall
and have the list delivered to the
polling place or town hall
have the list delivered to the polling
place i also do think that every clerk
that i've talked to
and it's been numerous who wants to use
pull books
um acknowledge that they would show up
to the polling place with a paper
checklist because they want that backup
right
just as just as you all wanna in the
committee no
moderator clerk who's running a polling
place is going to want
to run it without making sure that
they're prepared for anything
right and that's why our elections run
so smoothly because of all of their hard
work
and that's part of their work and they
understand that and so i you know i
i strongly suspect we'd see paper
backups um
ready for for any situation because they
know um they want to be ready as well
thank you any further questions from mr
o'brien
i'm not seeing any so thank you mr
o'brien is there anybody else
here this morning in attendance who'd
like to speak to this bill
this is a public hearing on sb 46
relative to electronic poll books
i'm not seeing anybody oh hold on i've
got a question it looks like
uh pam does somebody have their hand
up to speak at this point somebody just
labeled it department
and i don't know who that is has a
hi thank you representative griffin can
you hear me uh
everyone yes thank you hi i'll be very
brief because so many
uh points have already been made in
support of this
my name is sherry farrell i'm the town
clerk here in london derry
and as you've heard joan in milford
really led the
the um force on this and i jumped on
board with her
based on the knowledge that she had and
as representative mcdonald stated
here in londonderry it's been a complete
success but
we have guidelines through our
phenomenal secretary of the state's
office
um and as dave stated eloquently for us
they have watched and observed every
move that milford and londonderry has
made
and it's been a huge success um
everything that stated is accurate and
uh we're grateful
the towns that were mentioned that had
the early studies um were really more
just kind of exploration
points i'm not really jumping into the
reports and all that
i'll leave you with one cute story which
goes along with what pete from milford
had stated
about that you know if we're not allowed
to use these uh wonderful resources our
voters residents will
probably burst into tears here in
londonderry an 85 year old woman wrote
me a letter after
the general election and said that she
almost didn't come she voted every year
every time since she was 18 but getting
older she
just couldn't bear to come in and look
for that alphabetical
m again and wait in that line when you
know somebody else in a y
could just zip in and when she walked in
mind you and saw the pull pads and that
there were no
crazy letters anymore and you could go
to the first person that was open
she was elated and i'm just so grateful
for this new technology and it speaks to
what are
our you know we have to be progressive
in what's coming into the future with
technology
but also our seniors are very supportive
here in londonderry and i know milford
um of this technology and they're
grateful for it so
i'll leave you with that i thank you all
for listening so intently the great
questions that you're asking but i do
ask for your support on this
um thank you very much thank you
representative growing do you have a
question
mr dear thank you madam chair um miss
barrel
do you use the same process that was
described by mr vasilier
uh where a slip is printed and then
presented for the ballot and then you
keep the checklist
uh updated as you go through the day
absolutely and again you know this is i
know we can kind of tend to jump into
things and
new ideas but our secretary of state's
office through the years that's why we
are first in the nation and
and that's why here in election i i have
great pride in being part of the process
as a town clerk
because of the transparency and the
checks and balances that we have and yes
that is part of the requirement in us
getting involved in the test program
that we had to have that paper checklist
ready and available at all times and uh
and they actually came down and observed
in milford
and in londonderry to make you know sure
that we were doing it according to their
guidelines so
you know i have to thank them for their
support and that you know and it really
takes a village to make these things
happen one person can't think of
all the things that we need to take care
of
thank you does anybody else have any
questions
i'm not seeing anything on as far as
hands are on my screen so thank you very
much for joining us
is there anybody else in attendance who
wants to speak to sb46
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the publicarian sb46 and i'm going to
open our next bill hearing
we're starting a little late it was
noticed for 11 15
so thank you everybody for being patient
with me who's here for this bill
sb54 is relative to the absentee ballot
application form we have a few people
signed up to speak on this bill and at
this point i'd like to
ask who is going to be introducing the
bill
if you could raise your hand if you're
not already with us
is senator daniels here
i see griffin roberts who's a senate
um aide and perhaps he is um
here for one of the senators thank you
mr roberge if you want mute you can join
us
sorry good morning uh representative uh
griffin can you hear me
we can sorry about that thank you um for
the record i'm uh
griffin roberge legislative aide to
senator gaida
simply just want to let the committee
know that senator will be here
shortly to introduce saint bill 54. he
is currently driving down the highway
to uh get to his computer and to
introduce this bill
so um if the committee would uh call on
him when he is available that'd be
all right uh cheers senator gray
senator gray um i
i'd be happy to introduce this bill for
senator gaida he can
thank you comments at the same time uh
asking the absentee voters to provide a
photocopy
of a driver's license um much in the
same manner as we ask
people when they vote in person we've
modified that
very difficult for for some of our
voters to do that
so that if you look at the bill the way
it is right now
on page two um
and we're looking at uh lines
25 through pretty much the bottom of the
page
um
we tried to make that as easy on a voter
as
we could do it and still provide some
information
we ask that they put in if they have a
driver's license or
a non-driver id
that they put in the number in the state
or they can use the option of providing
the last four digits of the social
security number
and then we've got one other thing at
the bottom
is some contact information that the
town clerks have
town clerk if you were married in the
state of new hampshire
knows who married you who stood up with
you certainly they could
you know if you could verify that
information because the the records are
there for in every town clerk
um it may be the account number on your
your tax bill it may be
the account number on your water bill it
may be
the name of the person that's running
the shelter
that you stayed at last night it may be
um any number of things
that the town clerk can can verify
and they have a wealth of information
that if you just let your imagination go
a little bit
uh that can uniquely identify the person
again we're not trying to make it more
difficult for people to register
if they are the person that they say
they are
writing down those last four digits of
the social security number is not hard
not
you know but if they choose not to do
that
because uh they don't want to share that
information
there are other options out there that
they could uh use
um another one that comes to mind if
they registered a car
um certainly those records
are available to a lot of the town
clerks because they also function as the
tax collector
so again whatever the town clerk uh
can you know look up and verify
that's fine because the people who
should not be voting if someone were to
try to use your
your name your identity and try to vote
we're just trying to to weed out the
worst of the worst
and not make it difficult for the voter
not make it difficult for the town clerk
um the driver's license number and state
or run non-driver id and the
four digits of the social security
number are fields
in election net right now uh certainly
those could be
used that way again it's uh what we
think is a common sense
way of doing this and i mentioned
the u.s house bill hr1 before
and it still talks about being able to
use
no more than the last four digits of the
social security and identification
and things so we think that this is a
common sense bill
provides us some indication
i tell people that if propriety would
allow i could go there with
nothing in my hands nothing in my
pockets
and go in and sign four affidavit and
affidavits and vote um that's still the
case this doesn't take that away from
them
but it allows you know communications
between the people
um so uh enough said and
if the good senator when he gets here
wants to add to that i'd be certainly
happy
but since i did write the amendment that
did this
i might be able to answer your questions
senator gray just for clarification
you uh mentioned registration a couple
of times this bill
actually has to do with applying for an
absentee ballot correct
correct but in the registration form
there is an option to include the
driver's license number and state
and the last four digits of the social
security so it
can work together with that application
process
at the same time and provide information
that the voter may have already provided
when they registered and that being a
good check to make sure that
with very little trouble for the voter
and make it easy for everyone
that would be appreciated they enter
that information
thank you madam chair thank you senator
gray for taking the question
so just a point of clarification
if a voter was to pull an absentee
ballot
request and didn't want to show their
driver's license or any other id
they could simply give their their name
in the last four digits of their social
security number
if they did that is there a way to let's
say somebody come in and said they were
frank smith
and just gave four digits of a social
security number
is that enough information to verify
that person is who they say they are
again we're because we are on the
application for the absentee ballot
and they are already registered in the
system
um then their name
address and other information which they
also would be providing
on that application form and if they
provided that information
uh you know at the time they did the
request
you notice that in the lower section of
the bill it also allows the
uh town clerk to contact
the state or the local uh office
police chief or whatever to verify
so if they did not provide say the uh
driver's license number in state
um and you know or did provide that
and it wasn't in election net then
they could certainly go and look that up
thank you
further questions from committee members
i'm not seeing any oh representative
meerhead
thank you madam chair uh thank you
senator
i'd like to ask about the phrase one or
more of the following
on line 25 and
is one of the following sufficient or
are
voters expected to fill out
all four of the following if they can
one is sufficient some
may want to provide additional
information i
certainly wouldn't uh stop them from
doing that
the two easiest for the clerks
would be the driver's license numbered
state
and the last four digits of the social
security number
which there are fields in the statewide
database
often referred to as election net for
recording that information
and should they request ballots in the
future if they provided either one of
those numbers
they could be verified with the
information
they previously provided may i have a
follow-up madam chair
representative thank you madam chair
i'm concerned that voters applying for
an absentee ballot will
be anxious that their absentee ballots
count
as they're filling out this
and um and they may wonder whether
one of these is sufficient to
make their absentee ballot count um
if if one or two of these are actually
better ways
of making ensuring the ballot counts on
others
have you thought about singling those
out so that an anxious voter can be
certain that their absentee ballot will
thank you representative uh many many
many of these absentee ballots the
person is actually
standing in front of the town clerk at
the time uh
so if they provided their driver's
license there's a separate
section in state law that talks about
not having to do signature requirements
which are enjoined
right now us from doing that but
there is a statewide system that you can
go in and check on your absentee ballot
it's available on secretary of state's
website
and you can certainly do that remember
that we are
there's also a piece of legislation
that's coming before you
um that just expands upon the opening of
the outer envelope
that many of the clerks and moderators
asked for that to be extended well the
legislation that
should be coming in front of you uh
expands that
so that um even several weeks before
uh the election uh the clerks will be
able to
establish a procedure uh open those
envelopes
inspect them and then provide feedback
to the voter if there is any
um additions changes that need to be
you know if they provide more than than
one that's fine if they provide one
thank you representative growing
thank you madam chair thank you senator
gray for taking that question
um i uh from rochester as you are
appreciate your serving our
our district uh in line
27 and 28 the town clerk is authorized
to verify
the driver's license or non-driver's
license id number
if the person gives the last four digits
of the social security number does the
town clerk have
access to the social security number of
the person to verify
that that is those are the correct
digits
uh not that i know of um there could be
some records out there that uh
a town clerk could know about that i
don't know about
uh but remember this information is
going to be put into election net
uh when they provide it and then in
subsequent uh
um times that they would be able to
check that against the information that
was provided previously
thank you further questions from
i'm seeing none thank you senator gray
for being here and for stepping in
um also also signed up to speak
on this bill is a todd fahey
i'm not seeing any oh
mr fahey with uh permission i'm going to
re recognize senator gaida he joins
us uh welcome senator gaida we hope you
didn't drive
too fast this morning but uh senator
gray has introduced your bill and we've
been taking questions and he's been
taking questions as you
have heard welcome thank you madam chair
members of the committee
i appreciate your indulgence there's
nothing i can add to what senator gray
has provided
uh in fact i i most of the credit for
this bill i introduced original
legislation
uh senator gray then worked extensively
with me to
to provide what is necessary as opposed
to what i had thought was necessary and
i'm very grateful to him
and the members of the committee
thank you any questions for senator
gaida
all right great mr fahey you have joined
us
welcome thank you madam chair
good morning members of the committee uh
i am indeed todd fahey i trust you can
hear me okay
we can lovely thank you i am todd fahey
i'm the state director of aarp new
hampshire
um we have some 215 000
members in the granite state uh the
great majority of whom vote and are very
uh
engaged in all things political and
civic
uh in fact our organization has long
been very focused
on a nonpartisan civic engagement and
participation in our political process
we
in our involvement in these issues is
nothing new
i have submitted written testimony which
i provided to the committee
and i would start by saying we do we do
oppose this bill
uh and i understand uh the senator's
comments and the reasons for it but we
we we appear in opposition to the bill
because
really we oppose things that create any
barrier to voting
and i want to give you a perspective
that i think is important in this case
um the whole idea of a driver's license
or
social security number we might all
assume that's an easy thing
to provide even the last four digits um
or that it's it's easy to figure out
what the numbers are
on a utility bill i don't think that's
necessarily so
um and it is certainly more burdensome
than what we currently do and and i
believe i understand
why the the effort is happening now to
do what we're doing
but it would also say that some 30 to
40 percent of granite staters voted
absentee in the last
election by virtue of uh the pandemic
and
the bipartisan legislation which um
that both chambers passed and the
governor supported
we also supported that legislation uh
and certainly
in any given year it's about 10 percent
of the electorate from the best
information i have from the secretary of
state's office
votes by absentee so it is really
important that there is no
there is no impediment to to
voting and i think to the extent that
this creates one
like somebody couldn't find their
identification or their license or they
could not recall the number
or they they didn't have their social
security card or the last four digits of
it
it's a barrier it's a burden and you
know i would come back to the point of
these are fundamental rights and there
are two that i really highlight and you
all know well and
in you know new hampshire we're blessed
to have a great
a great house and a great senate and and
our elections are run well here
um but article 11 is is amongst the
rights that we enjoy is the right to
vote
and and any anything that makes it more
difficult
for a person to enjoy that franchise in
new hampshire particularly since
we really had in the past very
uneventful elections i mean in the in
the 2020 election
and again this according to secretary of
state's office i know we have one town
we're having a recount
but generally the elections were secure
and well run
i mean the vast majority of it
and you know article 11 really talks
about the fact that the fundamental
right to vote is a right that is so
important and if people
exercise that right via absentee ballot
they ought to be able to do with new
hampshire
easily and readily and without
impediment and
you know there's another there's another
article we talk about
with much less frequency and it really
hasn't been changed since 1754 and it's
about the inculcation of social virtues
and
you know we we residents and citizens of
new hampshire i'm a native of the state
so i i
was born here and been here an awfully
long time
we look to our elected officials to to
really safeguard
the fundamental principles of the
constitution and what is really more
fundamental
then the right to cast one's ballot um i
and i do talk about uh article 38 and i
don't know that we talk about it a lot
but in a time when these are these are
things and and
concepts that were drafted you know
hundreds of years ago
to really make sure that we weave
tightly into the fabric of
our of our democracy those things that
we all hold dear
so um with those two thoughts and the
third thought is
there might be some privacy act concerns
under federal law
um i'm not going to say with the def
with certainty that there are
i would just flag it for the committee's
consideration
um and it may be nullified by the fact
that you're only requiring four
digits of the social security number but
nonetheless it's something worth
contemplation
and so for these reasons um we would ask
that
that this uh not pass out of committee
and
uh without certainly further changes to
be sure that there's no impediments to
uh
to a granite stater's right to vote
are there questions from mr fahey
representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you mr fahey
for taking my question
are you aware of anybody in your
organization or any of your members that
am i aware of them um
i can't say that i i i do or don't know
if if they have one or not
okay follow-up question representative
thank you um you mentioned the privacy
act
and um if you're aware of
any way that the current proposed
legislation would violate that could you
supply that
specific information to the committee
for us
sure uh i think i i did put some written
testimony
representative in and and that would be
the extent of the position i i didn't
say it with the certainty that it was a
violation i simply
flagged it for the committee's um uh
consideration as you go about
considering this legislation
and then secondarily to go back to your
point it's not necessarily about
the the social security number
representative it's it's whether people
have the ability to recall it
and to produce that information without
having to maybe
go to the go to the social security
office or
go through additional steps to provide
that information that may not may be
readily available to you or i but it may
not be readily available to some
and that was the position we take
thank you for the question any other
questions for
of our committee members for mr fahey
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you uh mr fahey do you
i just got the state constitution and
started reading article 38
it goes on to say that the people have
the right to require their law givers
to exact and to to form and execute the
laws necessary for the good
administration of government
government government wouldn't this fall
under that and i just want to make a
note that
i i recently cared for my elderly
mother-in-law for
many many years and at my fingertips at
all times
was a file that says important id and
papers
i can i could get it at a moment's
notice because i had to
every time she had a doctor's
appointment or medical care
was that is this something that's too
burdensome for
your members thank you for the question
representative the last few sentences i
didn't out here
i i did hear your comments i could speak
to them i just want to make sure i'm
responsive
something about our members i was just
reading from the
state constitution from article 38 which
which requires of lawmakers to form and
execute laws necessary for the good
administration of governance and
wouldn't this fall under that
with suitable amendment it certainly
would representative um
and i think i would i would hearken back
to the beginning of article 38
and it says a frequent recurrence to the
fundamental principles of the
constitution
um which is the first sentence and the
drafters were
not ones to um be reckless with language
so i do think with suitable amendment
and and i recognize that you were going
about the work of the people
and i think that the work of the people
and the charge of article 38 would
require
further questions further questions from
committee members from mr
faye mr fahey i actually have a couple
of questions well i think i'm welcoming
you back to our committee is that right
we've heard from you on other bills
right so welcome
thank you uh and
you said that you're um live here in new
hampshire
um my recollection is you might have
been out of this state for a few years
and um i'm saying that because i'm
looking at your testimony and talk about
sb
54 um requiring a reason
for voting absentee ball
for taking an absentee ballot are you
aware that's currently in the statute
and there's nothing in this bill that
um thank you for the question
representative i'm speaking only to the
requirement
of an additional information to
be provided so as to exercise the right
to vote via absentee ballot
um and no i have not been out of the
state i was i was i've been
here very much i haven't gone very far
frankly for quite a while
all right well that's good because your
letter says specifically
that sb 54 requires certain things and
those are currently in statute
so i just wanted to clear that up um
as to your comments as to um
the constitution you did a lot of work
on
article 11 and all the amendments so
thank you for that
um so my final question my question
would be then
um is there anything specific in your
testimony
that comes from the organization that
you represent aarp
there's a lot of constitutional
arguments but i'm curious to see whether
aarp um based on its members has
something specific
well i would thank you for that question
uh madam chair in
two two points uh i wouldn't be
testifying if the testimony was not
consistent with aarp policy on voting
um and okay so my testimony is entirely
consistent with the aarp
policy on ensuring that the franchise is
not
uh denied or made more difficult to to
any voter in the united states
particularly those who are members and
those who are over 50 plus
um and so i would speak to that issue
and then secondarily i mean certainly
you know people
our members have you know great concern
uh about
about their ability to vote and to vote
safely
and to exercise their right um that's
something that that we have been
involved with for
for years and certainly as recently as
last year when we did i did indeed
testify before your committee
all right i think did i answer your
question man i'm sure if not i'm happy
to go further
no that's fine if i have a further
question i'll just follow up with you
thank you um any other questions from
panelists
all right i'm seeing none so thank you
mr fahey
also signed up to speak on this bill is
and i
see your your chair has to take her
and thank you very much for joining us
ms says yeah hello
can you hear me we can yeah
thank you very much madam chair for
allowing me to speak
um i would like to bring in a few points
about this bill
first of all the language when i read it
one or more
of the following um that should be
provided
that was confusing even for me and
created some anxiety
so i i wonder if it would be better to
simplify the language and just say
one of the following since this is
sufficient
not requiring um secondly
i would like to mention that recalling
social security number
is not as easy for some people
as it would be for others my mom is over
she's 66 and she always has difficulty
recalling her social security number
so it may seem like it would be
something straightforward but even like
looking for
like account number for some uh
utilities
or other information might be cumbersome
and would certainly
add additional barrier um to request an
absolute vote
um my parents are naturalized citizens
and
even following my basic instructions for
them
is um requiring some level
of you know reading comprehending
but any additional information always
always adds additional layer of
complexity
which should certainly be determined and
i can imagine that
is more difficult for elderly people or
those with
disabilities as well and uh the last
point is um i think these bills are
requiring the signature of the person
who is assisting
in filling out the form um
which would also be difficult because
sometimes assistance can be provided
over the phone
or the elderly person might be living
alone
and they might be showing this form or
discussing it through
like what we call tele you know
communication video
something like that and so that person
may not be able to sign the form
which would certainly be additional
barrier so i would like to speak in
opposition to this
bill um and i agree with many of the
points that were raised
previously by um um
mr from the ep yeah
okay yeah
so thank you for listening thank you
very much for
joining us this morning for the hearing
does anybody on the committee have
i'm not seeing any thanks a lot and
thanks for signing up ahead of time
and that is the last person that i have
signed up to speak
on this bill is there anybody else in
attendance
who wants to speak on this bill
representative horrigan
there now i'm unmuted i'm representing
timothy oregon i represent grafford
county district six
which is the towns of durham and madbury
um durham is in fact a college town so i
was pleased to see that they did
recognize the reality that uh
drivers licenses from other states
thanks to a
interstate compact which we between
all the other states and actually all
the canadian provinces one driver's
license
is punchable with another so that's
something that we lose
track of a lot like we're losing track
of it and this is a
different this is not within the purview
committee but like even over like
the vaccine uh rollout and certainly
over voting so
um i i testified against
the original version of this bill in the
senate uh election law municipal affairs
committee and this
isn't quite as the original version of
ill was
even more uh misguided but this is a
totally unnecessary unnecessary bill um
and this also requires people to write
down information on the absentee ballot
form which they
may not necessarily want to share with
all the people who
uh look at a special cajon election nets
and i'm sure the security and lexington
is good but still there's people on
there who you might not necessarily want
to know your driver's license um that's
usually between me and the dmv that's
why concerned or even the last four
digits of my social security number
i'm not much younger than the young
woman's uh
grandma mother and i'm pretty sure i
know the last four digits of my social
security number
but i personally often mix them up with
the last four digits of my credit card
number if i was asked so that's uh
i think there's there's no need for us
there isn't really any procedure for
what to do if the clerk gets
what appears to be a bogus driver's
license number or both a social security
number and i don't
by what senator gray said i don't think
they really have any
i don't think they can just necessarily
look up that data in the other files and
verify it so
um i this bill is just one more attempt
to overcomplicate
the electoral process if anybody was
doing this on a large scale
you know having fictitious uh absentee
ballot uh
applications that would be caught anyway
despite what people say the attorney
general secretary of the state's office
do pay a lot of attention
to uh voter fraud which also of course
is a felony so it's very risky so if
somebody was doing
multiple fake absentee valid
applications i'm quite confident they
would be caught i'm quite confident that
they could be published
they could be punished very severely
anyway so all this
thing doesn't just make but it's already
a difficult process more difficult for
average citizens you just want to uh do
their civic duty and
vote so i would say uh i would say you
should uh find this bill any speed to
legislate and um
i don't know if any significant the fact
that you're hearing it today instead of
putting it off till after our
after uh april 7th through 9th if
indeed you are planning to fast track
this and execute today so it can be on
the calendar
next week i hope your decision will be
something other than ought to pass like
preferably inexpedited to legislate so
that's uh
that's basically what i have to say
about the bill so
i think thanks for recognizing me sorry
it's a little bit slow
getting unmuted and i suppose i can
answer any questions if anybody wants to
ask me anything
there are some people who want to ask a
question representative
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking that question
um do you see any need
for assuring that the identity of a
person
requesting an absentee ballot remotely
uh
that we do make some assurance that that
person is who
he or she says she here she is or do you
think
we should just simply take their word
for it that they are that person
um i think i'll just say i think the i
think
the uh protections are already in place
are sufficient i know
my town clerk and every count clerk
takes your job very seriously i know the
supervisor
are checklists and they're uh they're
trained to detect fraudulent activity
and this bill that passed would not help
them
do that because there's probably still
ways that a criminal
you know a sufficiently the turbine
criminal um
could still like could still try to gain
the system so i
i think all this will do is like confuse
a few people who
uh who are maybe struggling with their
paperwork anyway but are still
they'll still have the right to vote and
still should vote and also um
it also allows orders as you provide
certain information that's put in a uh
a form that uh that probably
formed and maybe other unauthorized
people can see in the database
that you know we don't i don't
necessarily 100 trust
but i know it's necessary so that you're
putting information
leaving lying around like i know i most
sensible people like
try not to provide uh when unnecessary
so i would say i would say the
protections we already have are are
sufficient and certainly there's no
uh like what some people said there's no
evidence of massive
fictitious absentee ballots out there so
i'm just saying what we already have is
sufficient that our i trust my town
clerk i chose my supervisor the
checklist you know and i
trust those in other communities
including rochester so that
that's that's my answer
i'm talking to myself the host i got
reminded that i'm
i was muted to cough and didn't unmute
representative growing
yes follow up please representative
growing go ahead
um representative morgan i'm from
rochester
a city of a little over 30 000 people
and our clerk in rochester is very
capable
but i doubt if she knows 30 000
people by name or by voice uh
to be able to recognize if someone
applying for an absentee ballot
is uh john smith or is not john smith
how how is the safeguard there to assure
that person is again who he or she says
she is
i don't know me mike my town clerk
and also well actually our assistant
congressman
every community 15 000 people have to
decide comparable and they
they're pretty with it so i think
they don't actually need to know
everybody my name or site and i don't
know
like why why writing down this
information is going to really
help them that much but they know what's
normal and what's not they know
they know when they're being scammed and
when they're not being scammed so i i
i just uh i think i trust them even in
the larger larger communities
so even uh i would even trust the city
thank you representative horgan
representative mooney
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm just wondering if you know uh if
it's acceptable
uh for example if a voter's ballot
were to be nullified by an invalid
absentee ballot are you familiar with
that scenario
or do you know of any acceptability
related to that
i'm probably not the right person the
that is
tracked you do uh if you do show up
at the polling place after there's an
absentee ballot in your name the uh
and we've been modifying that somewhat
in order to require
more processing um you can cast the
ballot in person so that's probably
something you might wreck more at the
secretary of state but that's i mean
that's
something that can happen even if you
have this bill and certainly they do
publish the names of people who applied
for absentee ballots and that's
one of the reasons why they do it in
case there's a either a clerical error
or an attempted fraud so that's uh
that's a concern already so that's uh
um i really uh i know uh
the attorney general's office secretary
state's office do actually do
uh pursue voter fraud and i've actually
uh
don't recall seeing that particular that
particular scenario playing out but um
you should uh
i mean that question probably is better
directed at them and certainly
i understand the concern that certainly
would be good reason not to
not to pass on this bill today if that
was indeed uh
what you what what the chair or whoever
what the share had in mind but that's uh
yeah so it's
it's already that's already an issue
it's something that can happen this bill
isn't going to prevent it it's just
going to make things harder for the
clerks and harder for the voters so
thank you representative horrigan
representative horrigan you mentioned
that you have some trouble with
uh remembering your social security
number
what about the other documents that
senator gray
brought up that could be used if you
discuss with your town clerk um
would you do you find those impossible
to
access as well i just you'd only need
one of them
um i mean i wouldn't be that big a deal
for me but i'm uh i'm a relative
i mean sometimes i'm a little spacey but
there's lots of people
lots of people whose memories are worse
than mine or whose life support
disorderly than mine so i
just uh i mean personally for me
you know i could have my driver's
license with me at all times i actually
despite what i said i
am fairly confident that i do remember
my social security number but there's
people who
have a harder time with that with me but
they still have the right to vote
they're still capable of making a
diligent decision and also
frankly much as i love my town clerk
and she's very trustworthy i don't
necessarily want to have to tell her
what my driver's license number is i
even though i'm sure she could look it
up in the dmv database i don't
necessarily want to follow
left where this is my social security
number are the context where
it's not necessary you know i don't
necessarily want to burden her with all
that stuff or trust her with all that
stuff so that's uh
and uh all this does would stop for
individual voters uh you know it's
an organized attempt to vote or fraud
would still be
carried out without it but it would uh
fire
it would be i'm quite confident it would
be caught and it's a pretty serious
felony if you do do it anyways i don't
think anyone's
going to falsify mrs jones's uh absentee
ballot just to cast a second vote i
think that's a fantasy
so i you know once again also those
concerns should probably be best to be
brought up
with the attorney general the secretary
of state's office who
probably are listening in on this and
also
this is also something you can bring up
in some community so
it's uh you know you wanna i think if
you do wanna move forward with this
ability it's a bad idea you certainly
don't wanna pass it as it is today you
wanna verify right thank you
representative horgan
is there are there any further questions
i'm not seeing any so thank you
representative horgan
also asking to speak to this bill is
can you hear me we can hi okay thank you
um i just wanted to bring up so as part
of the um
as a co-chair of the new hampshire city
and town clerks legislative committee
we are not in support of this bill um
we i do have a suggestion that i'll
bring up at the end
but the first thing um
the the few concerns is number one we
have no access to verify
anybody's social security number we just
don't have it it's not an election that
it's not
there's no way so anybody could write
any four numbers down they want and
i don't know so i don't know what that's
going to prove for verification
um secondly driver's license numbers
changed in the last two years
so if you've been a voter for 10 or 15
20 years the driver's license number
that is
in election net is not the drivers
license number that is on your license
right now so again
verifying a driver's license number
would be difficult
so the way and and i will do want to
state that you know in
and we recently had record numbers all
of us of uh absentee voting
and um i have to say in milford we've
we've have never had a fraudulent
absentee voter
to date one of the things that prevents
that is
when somebody mails in an absentee
ballot request
that request is mailed to the address on
record
so in my mind that is the way that we
prevent
fraud from those absentee ballot request
forms that are
mailed in or dropped off prior to
having the ballots ready and my
suggestion would be
if we'd like to amend this bill would be
that we just
add in that if you are going to request
an absentee ballot in person
and vote that day get your ballot that
day
that they just show us an id there is no
requirement right now
to show an id when you pick up an
absentee ballot in person and and i
think that that would that would address
senator gray and senator guida's um
issues with that um because any absentee
ballots then that we are mailing out are
going to the
mailing address on record and any
absentee ballots requested in person
the person would be required to show you
id and i'll and i'll tell you nobody
would have a problem with that because
everybody that
shows up in town hall um to request an
absentee ballot when we have them
they always want to show me an id
because they're just so used to doing it
at voting
um the other thing that my concern
about having the last four of somebody's
social security number and their
driver's license number on those
absentee ballot request forms
is that so many times people come into
town hall
and they'll fill out an absentee ballot
request form and they
just leave it anywhere so then their
private info is out there
for somebody else to pick up and find or
they're mailed to the wrong address
somebody else in town hall opens it um
again that's private information and
and i just think that by requiring that
a photo show an id when doing it in
person would
would help relieve those issues
and again i thank you for listening to
my
to our views thank you very much for
coming and joining us on this bill also
this morning does
anybody on the committee have any
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much
also uh i saw a hand raised to speak on
this was
did you still want to speak like
your hand disappeared miss mccain if
you're with us if you unmute i think you
will join us
yes hi hi good morning thank you
mountain chairwoman and
and welcome um thanks to you all for
your time spent on these important
issues
again i wanted to thank my colleague
joan um for speaking before me
um we heard some comments about folks
looking out for the interests of voters
which obviously is where your
your emphasis should be but i wanted to
selfishly
stand up for the interests of our the
town clerk who
um when i read the proposed legislation
i was quite
taken aback for how much discretion now
is being put on the shoulders of the
town clerk
um uh where because in fact it says
give us one of these two things and if
not talk to your town clerk
and i i'm just concerned that um
a bj's card um if somebody writes down
their bj's number for me
might be okay but a bj's number for joan
wouldn't be
and so i'm i i just think there's
there's a little bit
too much uncertainty about well what
what are we trying to prove and then um
senator gray indicated that we have
access to a wealth of information
and absolutely that is true but we are
also sworn to use that information
only for the purposes for which we've
been granted that access
so we can't go diving into the motor
vehicle
database and check out a plate number or
we can't go diving into the vital
records
um database just to see who married
somebody because we're curious so i
i'm a little bit a little bit concerned
about how we practically would
would um confirm this information and
then i i
did take to heart the question um that
one of your um
panel raised about do we think there's a
need to identify somebody who is
requesting an
absentee ballot and i think the
application
again is is signed under penalty of
perjury
we do um we do confirm that they are a
registered voter and as jones said
we do confirm the address that it's
being mailed to an address
that we have on record or if they've
asked us to mail it to their home in
florida
they have to um they have to list their
hanover domicile and so we have that
as well and then if this is truly
designed to catch the worst of the worst
as we heard
when the bill was introduced um again i
i i i think this is adding another
level of complexity and um frustrating
exchange between the clerk
and the voter um that again
we end up having to sort of try to do
our best to navigate
um and and i'm just not sure
that we're creating that friction for
any
um any problem that's been illustrated
as worthy of a solution
so um thank you for taking my comments
and i would urge the committee
to um to not support this bill
thank you thank you very much for
joining us this morning and speaking is
there anybody
in the committee who would have a
question
for miss mckellen
anybody on the committee have a question
raise their hand i'm not seeing anybody
thank you very much miss
up representative prudhomme o'brien has
a question
the quick question uh thank you uh i was
wondering
where you're from and what town you
represent
oh sure sure i'm from the town of
hanover and we have about
ten thousand people on our um voter
checklist and so
so we most of our absentee ballot
requests
especially through the pandemic in fact
were coming through
via email and so um so again and i would
heartily agree with um ms daigle that
when people
appear before us they fully expect to
show us a photo id
um again i'm not i'm not sure um
other than the the the checks we have in
place with
um the addressing and the knowing that
they're
a registered voter and that the voters
signing under penalty of perjury
um again how we would confirm remotely
um a bj's card so
thanks any other questions
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us
is there anybody else here in attendance
who would like to
speak to the bill that we're having a
public hearing on it is senate bill
54 relative to the ballot application
form
i'm not seeing anybody so uh
senator gray uh thank you madam chairman
i just wanted to uh respond to
representative
mooney's question about absentee ballots
and voting in person
uh right now that the state law
does not allow you to start processing
absentee ballots until
at least two hours after the polls open
those ballots both the absentee and the
regular ballots
are processed through the same checklist
and there's two conditions
uh where you would not be able to vote
in person
uh had an absentee ballot been processed
and that those things about processing
them
is if you've opened the internal
envelope
or you've marked the red av on the
checklist
at the time okay those two things
would preclude the voter who might want
to come in
and not have his absentee ballot counted
um from uh actually uh going through and
voting in person
so if that answers your question i hope
that you're good
and i'll keep my bj's card in my pocket
because you guys wouldn't be able to
verify that anyway so
there you go any other
questions for senator gray or senator
geider i believe is still with us
he is and a last call for comments from
the public
representative home o'brien thank you i
i have a question for senator gray
is
when you were writing this bill or
discussing this bill in the
did it come up that that that the town
clerks would not be able to verify some
of this information
so that makes me wonder is it is it
requested because
in the future should there be an
investigation it may be good to have
this
information to verify things
uh let me answer this way
um that section near the end of the bill
and i don't have the
the bill well i guess i do have it up on
my screen
um we
specifically in there allow the clerks
to go in
and look at the dmv or contact
their local or state police to get the
information about the driver's license
number
okay and but not everyone has
a new hampshire driver's license has
been pointed out by our representative
from durham
uh and not everyone has a voter
uh i should say a non-driver id
uh so what other things are out there um
last four digits of the social security
number is something right now
that i don't know how a town clerk would
verify that
uh unless that information was provided
at the time that they registered
but once provided
it would be entered into election net
and should someone
try to do that again with a different
set of four digits
then we certainly would be able to start
asking questions that those two numbers
because as far as i know my social
security number has
never changed okay
but remember that other section uh
hey there are so many things that
uh there are that the clerks do have
access to
and this bill um
maybe it needs to be strengthened in
that section but
this bill provides the authorization for
the clerk
to go in and verify um
who married myself and my wife if i
chose
to uh to to use that as the information
uh who was my best man who was the um
you know maid of honor all those things
are on
the marriage certificate that is on file
in the state system uh i mean there is
so many things out there that could be
done
now this is also
will be trained by the secretary of
state
and i imagine that one of the things
that they will train
is that failing all else they can sign
an affidavit
i would be a little suspicious that that
would be the only thing that they could
do
but again that's not my suspicions that
uh
that are going to rule on this this you
know place
uh but you know i think that there
are yes the the last four digits of
social security number
um are something that we do have as an
option to provide on the
registration card it is not mandatory
so that's the best answer i can give you
representative
representative lane thank you madam
chair
personally i'll get this to a question
but
i have grave issues with requiring
people to divulge any
of their social security number it was
it is not an identification number it is
used by the federal government
and creditors to identify you
for income and to make sure that you get
the correct benefits under the social
security act
why are we using it for voter
identification
it's not the intent of a social security
number
why did you choose that we are
providing um the opportunity to use
something
okay now i'm uh assuming that
that you either own or rent a home here
in new hampshire
okay if you rent the home and you can
provide the name
of the person who owns that residence
that is something that the clerk can
verify they have the property tax
records
if you own a home then certainly you
have a tax bill
or other information so if it were
the only piece of information that you
could provide
i'd say yeah we probably are going too
far
but you know we're not
we we have it open so that you can
provide a
plethora of information
and just choose one of them just choose
one
may i have a follow-up please follow up
um thank you
uh senator i guess in the drafting of
this
um well what if the town
every town court does things differently
what if my town clerk
only wants the social security number or
my driver's id
that doesn't have the correct number on
it because when i registered
before it's changed and you or i or
anyone
else that finds that out should report
that to the secretary of state so that
that town clerk can be
re-educated correct but i want to get an
absentee ballot because i
i'm just saying we're putting a lot on
the boater or
putting obstacles in front of the voter
and i will desist at that point
thank you representative muirhead
thank you madam chair um i want to just
clarify
if i may senator is this bill asking for
information as proof of identity that we
know
town clerks do not possess i such as the
last four digits of the social security
number
um they would not normally have the
last four digits of the social security
number that i know of
unless it was provided as voluntary
information
on the application but it was a piece of
uh that uh most people have
access to um you know my grandsons
um by the time they were six their
father had to
file uh the taxes and they already had a
social security number at the tender age
of six months
uh so again you know
is this thing perfect um no it's not
uh does it uh you know we're making a
lot of
about this you know the constitution
provides a lot of things
constitution provides that um
just as a comparison um the right to
bear arms
all right what do i have to do if i want
to exercise my right to bear arms
i have to go through background checks i
have to provide information
i have to i have to i have to i have to
well now we look at the constitution and
says you've got the right to vote
well when that constitution was written
um
wasn't it that it was only landowners
that were males that
you know could have the right to vote
things have changed over time
and again i think that there is a
an interest in the state to make sure
that our elections
are conducted in a manner such that
every
citizen of the united states has the
right to vote
unless they're convicted of a felony and
currently serving
a sentence but the question is is
where do they have the right to vote and
rsa 654
in new hampshire says that
once they've established their domicile
and they've picked new hampshire as that
place more than any other
where they want to interact socially and
civilly and participate
that once they've established that
domicile
they have the right to vote in new
hampshire okay
what does that mean established thank
you
thank you senator gray representative
prudenhome o'brien thank you ma'am
my question i'm not sure if this is
correct to ask senator gray but you may
know
or senator guyton may or later we may
hear from
deputy scanlon but when it comes to
it just came up so i want to ask and i
want to talk about it
which we talked about there was a
concern about driver's licenses
and number changes of of driver's
licenses
and and i'm looking at my own driver's
license and i'm seeing a pattern
so wouldn't that be able to be
established by anyone who's
trying to find out the driver's license
number and notice the change
i recall a number just a few years ago i
had a conversation with a police officer
and he was telling me about driver's
license numbers and telling me about how
he could
he would know by asking me just a few
questions he could tell me what my
driver's license number was
just by asking a few questions and he
did so
you would know it by my birthday my um
because because the driver's license
number
used to be and mine used to be the first
letter last letter of my last name
my first letter of my first name and
then a series of numbers that talked
about my date of birth
and then a sequential number depending
on who else might have that
that was all changed and one of the
reasons why you see
in this bill is allowing the clerks to
go in
and look at the records or
ask for assistance is because their
record even if that was
given at the time of registration may
not match what the driver's license
number is now
which is more sequential random
depending on when you got the number etc
so
it is not does not match that pattern
anymore
thank you madam chairman um senator
did it come up in in the senate hearings
did anybody mention that not all city
clerks have access to uh
motor vehicle records because some city
clerks don't register cars it's the tax
collector that does it
uh if you look at the last page here it
says that they can
contact either the local police or the
state
to get that information okay further
question
representative go ahead um
also you mentioned the possibility of
looking up marriage records as an
example of
other means of identifying uh confirming
someone's
identity are you aware that every time a
clerk accesses the bureau of vital
records database to search a record
we're charged the clerks have charged
the fee for doing so
that may be a good thing to uh to
add to this bill is that the fee is
waived for the state right
if that's the case uh i was not
aware of that so that may be a good
catch representative bergeron
yeah and and one final question um
if a city or town is getting 9 000
absentee ballots for a presidential
election
this is adding a terrific burden on on
the clerks to be
verifying 9 000 applications to uh
before those ballots are either sent out
or or sent to the polls on election day
um i will check with the city clerk but
uh here in rochester uh we did receive
you know multiple requests uh but
uh again i believe that a very high
percentage of that
were people who actually came in and
voted in person
we actually in the community center set
up a satellite office
for the town or for the city clerk to be
able to process those people who came in
um wanting to do that so that
certainly reduced the burden on the town
clerks for
looking up any of this information and
trying to process them by mail
are there any further questions from
i'm not seeing any thank you senator
gray for jumping
back into the discussion here is there
anybody else in attendance who wants to
speak to the bill currently being
considered and that is
sp54 relative to the
application for absentee ballots
i'm not seeing any so i am going to
close the public hearing on
sb 54.
all right so that is the end of this
committee's noticed business this
morning i want to thank everybody for
attendance i want to thank
representative growing and
representative hayward for making sure
our room is still
i hope this worked out for everybody uh
i will not be scheduling anything
obviously for next week
uh we have enough to do with session
at the end of next week and then
hopefully we will have a
handle on the final amount of senate
bills coming over to get those scheduled
in april does anybody have anything else
they want to bring up
for the committee this morning or this
all right i'm not seeing anything so
thank you very much everybody for
attending
and participating representative ward i
hope